A long time ago when our great country was just being built,...
...there were the haves...
Money, money, money.
...and the have-nots.
The haves owned companies and industries...
...and they relied on their workers to, well, do the hard work.
The workers were proud of what they did.
They worked hard every day.
But they watched the companies and the haves get richer and richer...
...while they got poorer or stayed the same.
They had to work for as long as their bosses told them to work.
They didn't get overtime pay, they didn't get to take a break...
...and there was no guarantee they would be safe at work.
If they got hurt or even killed...
...the company didn't have to do anything about it.
This isn't fair.
The workers decided to do something about it.
But it was hard, the companies could just fire them.
Get lost!
So the workers joined in unity.
Together, they had a voice.
Together, they could demand things like fair wage, safe working conditions,...
...an end to child labor, sick leave, family leave, pensions.
Together, labor unions created something in between the haves and the have-nots: the middle class.
The middle class is very important.
It allows people to make better lives for themselves.
And the middle class has money to spend...
...and when they buy things, that money goes back into our economy.
And it makes America strong.